- [voiceover] Richard Serra, standing at
the foot of the steps,
looking into his sculpture.
- This is a piece called
"Intersection II".
It was built in 1992, 1993.
It consists of four identical plates,
even though you might think that
each plate is different.
Each plate is a single piece of steel
about 13 feet high,
and they're about 50 feet long,
probably upward of 30 tons.
They're made of conical shapes.
When you think of a cone,
you either think of a flower pot
or a lamp shade.
If you think of a section
of each of those being turned upside down,
that is how this piece is formed.
What that does is make three
different juxtaposed spaces,
a contained elliptical
space in the center,
and two flanking passages.
I think the best thing for us to do now
is walk into the central space
so we can see how this accounts for
a psychological feeling
of different spaces.
When you walk into this space,
immediately the sound is limited.
You're in a very, very contained space.
One large form is leaning toward you,
and the other leaning away from you,
which may make you think that
you have to adjust your balance.
Depending on your own experience,
there are references
that might come to mind,
nautical, cavern, enclosure, or whatever.
You feel that you're in a weighted space,
almost like the ballast
in the bottom of a ship.
- [voiceover] As you walk out the far
end of this central space,
turn to your left and step into the
narrow flanking space leading
back towards where you started.
- We're going to walk in between
two plates leaning away from you,
and what this does is it opens
itself outward toward the sky.
This space seems much more relaxing,
easier to traverse.
The fact that you can see through
to the open end before you arrive at it,
allows you to walk freely through it.
- [voiceover] When you
emerge from this space,
please turn to your left and walk over
to the passage on the far side.
- The interior plate is now
leaning toward you.
The exterior plate is also
leaning toward you,
and as the piece rises,
the space becomes more
and more compressed.
This space has much more of a
vertical lift to it.
I decided the height in relation
to my body movement.
At a certain point,
if work becomes too high,
you look up and the physical space
won't be registered with your body.
It just becomes like a building.
These pieces still have
their mill scale on them.
The grey aspect, which is still
kind of deteriorating,
eventually will crack and fade
and fall off completely,
and then you'll have
the dark rusted patina.
That patina will continue to
oxidize over eight years.
The reason this piece still has
its mill scale on it is that
it's been stored inside.